hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my euron greyjoy video so just
careful for spoilers if you're not
caught up on the TV show yet I'll be
talking about a few things that George
or Martin has mentioned about the
character - right now on the TV show
he's like the de-facto Ironborn villain
as crazy as the on an yar it's pretty
obvious that they're the protagonist we
want them to win they've stolen some of
your on ships but they have way less
than the thousand that are needed to
carry Daenerys his forces to Westeros so
there's a couple big problems that need
to be solved but that's effectively what
the Ironborn storyline has become
Daenerys coming to Westeros is just a
question of who brings her to Westeros
and who forms that alliance first will
Yara sex Daenerys is tits off into an
alliance or will Euron make her submit
now in the books that relationship
between those two storylines is a little
more complicated there are more people
involved
we have Victorian Greyjoy who's going
over with all the ships so they've
collapsed a lot of that Euron even has
dragon binder which I guess if you
really want to make jokes you could call
a metaphor for his dick the TV show was
a little bit clearer about that like
he's grabbing his crotch is he's like
I'm gonna make Daenerys to submit to me
but as we know what does nares do when
men try to make her submit she roasts
them alive so I don't think that anybody
believes that you're on is just gonna
sail over show Daenerys his dick and
that's gonna be the end of it they're
gonna conquer Westeros together but what
about those thousand ships that's
actually a really important plot point I
will be a little upset if they use the
mass transit work around because as
funny as it is to see Littlefinger fly
all over Westeros in the span of a
single episode building a thousand
sailing ships takes a long time even
with modern technology and I love the
idea that Euron has them basically
dismantling everything that's made of
wood on the iron isles to build all
those ships as if they'll build the
ships that in doing so they'll have to
dismantle most of their homes
but either way there's going to be some
conflict with Joran and because his
power is at sea it will probably take
place at sea so the real question with
his storyline is whether or not Theon
and Yara will gain the additional ships
needed to get all the troops over or if
they'll just take a smaller force or
even third option Euron will actually
make it around there eventually and
they'll just take the rest of his ships
by force the easiest way to get
something in Game of Thrones that's
relatively complex
rather than get a loan from the iron
bank to build it is to just take it from
someone else so that'd be an awesome
takedown for your entree joy but he's
actually a pretty big badass and he
sailed all over the world so he's
probably got a few aces up his sleeve
dragon bind her style even on the TV
show even though it doesn't seem like
the TV shows doing dragon bind her
here's my big question for you guys let
me know where you think the euron
greyjoy story is going to come to a head
this season do you think we'll see a
battle at sea and how do you think that
Theon and Yara are gonna get Daenerys
and all of her forces to Westeros do you
think they'll take a smaller force with
the ships that they do have or do you
think it's gonna be an iron bank
solution now there are no volantis so
they're not super close to the iron bank
but I would be willing to bet the iron
bank would be happy to bankroll Daenerys
thinking that she's probably the best
option for repaying all the loans that
they have lost and Stannis think about
how much money they sunk into him when
Stannis hired all those sell swords the
iron banks motto is the iron bank will
have its due and that's actually another
good thing - we'll have to talk about
after the series is over the crown is
still deeply in debt to the iron bank
but it's not necessarily related to the
euron greyjoy storyline I'll just laugh
if there's some sort of deus ex machina
solution at the end where urine just
MAGIX up a thousand ships and sails all
the way around the Horn of Westeros down
in the south up there slavers Bay like
when you weren't looking at me I was
making all those ships here they are
they're all ready to go the stuff that
Georgia our Martin has been teasing for
you're on story line is a lot more fun -
if you really like your on as a villain
you are going to love winds of winter so
in the latest material that George our
Martin has read in public the damp air
has visions of Euron conquering Westeros
wearing a shark teeth crown sitting on
the Iron Throne
in the suit of Valyrian armor with
someone who's you know relatively white
looking he can't quite make them out but
I think it's implied that it's Daenerys
so he's basically having visions of
Euron completing his mission of making
Daenerys submit in conquering Westeros
but on top of that Georgia our Martin
makes Iran even worse so the damp hair
is remembering to his childhood when
urine would sexually abuse him and his
other brother and then Euron admits to
killing all of their other brothers
remember urine and the damn pair are
both brothers of Balon Greyjoy Theon's
father they're both the aunts uncles and
they had a bunch of
the brothers that Euron admits to
killing so while the TV shows version of
your on just seems like a total [ __ ]
book version of your on is this
Granville like the psychopathic grand
villain
so hopefully that gets you a little more
pumped up for a snow bowl Jon Snow vs.
Ramsay style battle with this Ironborn
Daenerys storyline what I'm hoping is is
they push your on into next season and
we see something of a snow bowl let's
see with that storyline but we haven't
seen him in a while there's three more
episodes including episode eight tonight
so just be prepared for euron greyjoy
followup scenes in the next couple of
episodes because even if they push him
into next season they still have to
follow up with what's going on with him
before the end of this season but what's
gonna happen tonight is I'll post my
episode 8 video after it airs so be sure
to subscribe to get that there's also a
new round of the giveaway that's
happening right now all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber leave a
comment on this video so just remind
everyone when I post my episode 8 video
tonight even though the TV show has
really tuned you're on it's character
down a little bit I think he has
potential to be one of the best non
Ramsay villains on the show but while
you guys wait for my video to post
tonight you can click here to learn all
about Lady Stoneheart I kind of
explained her story in the books where
the TV shows probably gonna change about
that and you can click here for my
episode 7 video from last week thank you
so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight
you